[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du club de la
presse sur tv 78 la chaîne des yvelines
aujourd'hui pour m'accompagner non pas
en plateau mais en visioconférence
alexandre remarquer bonjour un
responsable du secteur de saint-quentin
pour toutes les nouvelles et de 7,8
actus.fr également nouradine agne
reporter marmite fm bonjour radio qui
émet depuis attrape sur le 88.4 fm et
puis deux journalistes de tv 78 à
grégory canal et rédacteur en chef
adjoint et patrice carmouze directeur de
la rédaction bonjour à vous deux bonjour
mais le fruit d'un espérant que le monde
aille bien en étant confiné nous allons
faire ce club de la presse dans une
version un peu différente
aujourd'hui nous avons un invité
justement pierre bédier bonjour à vous
bonjour président du conseil
départemental des yvelines et vous allez
nous accompagner pendant la première
partie de cette émission et au sommaire
du club de la presse ce mois ci depuis
le 17 mars le confinement s'applique à
toute la france comment vit-on cette
situation dans les yvelines nous verrons
comment les pouvoirs publics s
impliquent mais aussi comment les
citoyens se montre solidaire début de
confinement le 17 mars mais aussi
premier tour des municipales la veille
le 16 mars que va devenir ce scrutin le
second tour pourra t'il se tenir à la
rentrée le premier sera t-il à nu les
éléments de réponse à suivre avant de
refermer ce club de la presse nous
verrons aussi quelles sont les
personnalités du mois citoyens élus
personnalités ou personnes de l'ombre
chaque journaliste fera son choix
nous sommes le 24 avril nous débutons ce
club de la presse avec l'actualité du
mois
nous sommes le 24 avril et nous débutons
avec l'actualité du mois forcément nous
parlons d'une situation inédite depuis
ya six semaines
aujourd'hui la france est confiné
situation quasiment semblable dans le
reste du monde le pays est à l'arrêt
mais il a fallu continuer à le faire
tourner un peu
première question pour vous justement
pierre bédier comment s'est organisé le
département des yvelines
alors nous nous avons des missions que
nous devons continuer à assumer en
particulier en direction des personnes
les plus fragiles dont nous nous sommes
organisés de façon à ce que toutes nos
activités traditionnelles puisse
continuer avec toutes les mesures de
précaution alors c'est par exemple
l'aide sociale à l'enfance
on avait des milliers d'enfants placés
auprès de nous
on peut pas les mettre à la rue au
prétexte que on pourrait plus s'en
occuper
donc il a bien fallu s'organiser c'est
pas toujours simple nous avons aussi des
mamans qui sont enceintes leur grossesse
à travers les pays
il a bien fallu ces pays continuent à
fonctionner donc le département a
continué son action a continué à
recevoir les publics les plus fragiles
qu'il devait recevoir et pour toutes
celles et tous ceux qui n'avaient pas en
contact avec le public
et bien moi nous organiser en totalité
en télétravail vous avez pu continuer
malgré tout il ya eu des séances du
conseil départemental une séance aussi
qui a été organisée en visioconférence
on a eu l'occasion d'en parler pas
patrice je me tourne vers vous peut-être
pour faire un point aussi sur les
relations avec l'état parce que pierre
bédier nous expliquer que les choses ont
fonctionné mais malgré tout il ya eu
peut-être quelques fois des couacs
haussier est ce que vous avez ressenti
parce qu'on en parle beaucoup rapport
aux initiatives et prendre du
département des freins qui viennent de
l'état ou des administrations au centre
av
alors pour être très honnête le couple
état département a très bien fonctionné
dans département des yvelines
parce que ça tienne aussi
aux qualités des personnalités des
relations qu'on a dit c'est avec elle je
pense en particulier au préfet brot mais
aussi puisqu'on l'a découverte à la
directrice départementale de la rs qui
fait un travail tout à fait remarquable
donc nous n'avons pas senti localement
ses freins ensuite si vous voulez mon
sentiment sur ce qui s'est passé au
sommet un peu plus comment dirais-je
peut-être de transparence de vérité on a
bien vu des allers-retours sur les
marges qui va les menus dire qu'on
n'avait pas de masse qu'on allait
essayer d'en fabriquer en attendant ma
il fallait qu'on se débrouille mais que
le masque et dammam utile ça nous aurait
permis nous puisque c'est l'occasion de
faire une annonce sur votre antenne 2
comment mais plutôt les deux millions et
demi de masques que nous sommes en train
de rechercher auprès de plusieurs
fournisseurs que j'espère avoir menti
mais de façon à pouvoir par
l'intermédiaire des mers yvelinois en
particulier dans les petites communes
sont prêts près des armées l'a
désarçonné pouvoir faire une
distribution grand public
une rubrique analyse grégory souhaitait
intervenir pas patrice alesi juste avant
venait juste préciser parce que c'est
intéressant en période de crise
finalement on s'aperçoit qu'elle est au
fou avec l'expérience que vous pouvez
avoir le le meilleur endroit de décision
le meilleur le meilleur niveau de
décision
justement c'est à dire celui qui agit à
la fois la connaissance de ce qui se
passe sur les territoires et puis
l'efficacité des mesures crise c'est la
ville et département ces projets ne
cédez pas ou est ce que c'est la
coopération tous alors le coronavirus
aura agi comme un révélateur de toutes
les âneries ce administrative française
depuis 50 ans
ce qui marche et j'ai encore pu vérifier
c'est le couple commune qui est je le
prendrai bien le point d'entrée de tout
service public pour les français et le
département département dans sa fonction
et lui conseil départemental et dans sa
fonction n'est pas préfecture la région
pas sans intérêt là elle doit faire la
coordination sera pas la question des
transports
mais la réactivité elle est
dans ce couple là et c'est ce couple que
depuis 50 ans on affaiblit au moment de
la crise
on s'aperçoit que heureusement qu'il est
là sous grégory oui puisqu'on parle des
relations avec l'état et qu'on évoque
forcément cette date du 11 mai la fin du
du confinement le début du déconfinement
je voulais savoir car bédié comment vous
l'envisagez vous à l'échelle des
yvelines le président de la république a
appelé à s'appuyer en tout cas c'est sa
volonté sur les collectivités
territoriales sur les maires notamment
comment au niveau des yvelines vous
envisagez quel est votre état d'esprit
sur cette date du début du déconfinement
du 11 mai ce alors qu'on s'entende bien
on va donner notre avis mais je ne suis
pas certain qu'on nous laisse nous
organiser comme on l'entend alors que
nos concitoyens qui nous écoutent
company men que je ne prétends pas avoir
un pouvoir que jusqu'ici on ne m'a pas
donné comme un avion ne me donnera pas
pour moi la règle la plus intelligente
j'aurais de faire ce que d'autres pays
ont fait et ce que nous nous sommes
capables de faire si nous voulons c'est
permettre toutes les activités je dis
bien tout à condition que lorsqu'on
rentre dans un lieu où il ya plusieurs
personnes prennent systématiquement
qu'on ne fasse pas systématiquement la
température s'il y a à travers cette
prise de température suspicion
d'infection dont on ne connaît pas la
nature à ce moment là immédiatement la
personne est dirigé vers un laboratoire
point tests sérologiques pour savoir si
elle a simplement eu une les pep munne
une rage de dents ou le comique 19
si elle a le qi de 19 naturellement elle
reste chez elle elle est donc confiné le
temps ces trois semaines le temps de la
quarantaine
une demie quarantaine dont et
naturellement elle est suivie on utilise
et là il faut qu'on soit raisonnable
on utilise ces données téléphoniques
pour savoir avec qui elle a été en
contact pour faire une enquête
épidémiologique rapide et ainsi on peut
reprendre une vie normale
y compris à léo restants si dans une
salle de restaurant on a tous 36,1 de
température la probabilité pour qu'on en
contamine un autre est quand même très
limité
et si on ne reprend pas une vie normale
je ne sais pas comment on va faire
nous lutterons socialisation de donner
des surnoms sur les smartphones par
exemple j'ai sur mon bureau
pardonnez-moi mais j'en profite pour
vous le dire tous les croyez que je
reçois des les yvelinois et des
entreprises yvelinoise qui me disent
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire pour moi
le chaton breteuil et les fermes et d'un
château privé seul château où il se
débrouille pour faire venir du public et
pour être un autonomie ne demande jamais
d'argent public va bien falloir qu'on
les aide mais on peut pas on ne peut pas
dépenser l'argent qu'on n'a pas donc il
faut bien remettre la machine en route
avec naturellement très confiant bien
entendu mais il faut remettre la machine
en route voilà moi je suis vraiment
partisan de dorothée de tout faire pour
revivre normalement avec des activités
normales même si elles ont ralenti même
s'il ya des comptes
alexandre et et noureddine pour toutes
les nouvelles 7,8 actuelle faire et puis
marmite si vous souhaitez intervenir
aussi prêté remédier serait plutôt pour
une question sur sur les ehpad
il ya une ombre des cédants dans les
ehpad est ce que vous les aviez dit on a
vu qu'il ya un plan d'urgence notamment
à leur destination et je voulais savoir
si dans les prochaines années
faudrait-il repenser l'accueil de nos
aînés au nombre d'essais qui a eu un oui
on peut s'interroger sur la qualité
morale d'une société qui oublie un peu
ses aînés et 1
ils ont pourtant participé à une fête et
l'accueil des personnes âgées c'est
effectivement une grande question je
crois qu'on va avoir plein de questions
à se poser à l'issue est donc pas tout
de suite bien entendu le sur lesquels
des aînés je veux dire que nous venons
de mettre en place alors on est allé
aussi vite que possible parce que on est
très dépendant des décisions
administratives
encore une fois pour nos concitoyens
yvelinois qui nous regardent nous
écoutent tous les étapes vont être
testés le département finance un test
général des résidents et des
collaborations de départ pour vérifier
que leur cergy mais il a fait
naturellement qu'on se mette d'accord
avec les normes que les laboratoires
proposait c'est pour ça que c'est un
tout petit peu table donc dans deux
semaines où les épaves des vigneronnes
plus possible de l'épidémie et ont ainsi
pu également prendre des mesures de
précaution et de prévention radine oui
puis en mobilier les effectifs explosent
être un peu plus de 41 milliards on en a
parlé beaucoup cette semaine pour la
sécurité sociale aide aux entreprises
aux particuliers le département et
contribue fortement
plusieurs millions d'euros le
gouvernement la région le département
j'ai une question simple qui va payer ça
aura une incidence sur la fiscalité
forcément aussi des ménages peut être on
va on va forcément le payer tout ça
c'est de la dette et la tête faudra bien
la rembourser je ne crois pas que ceux
qui prêtent de l'argent
le fasse sans espoir de retour alors
dans ces prêts d'argent c'est un peu
compliqué mais il ya beaucoup les
banques centrales les banques centrales
réagissent bien ça c'est la grande leçon
on nous apprenait ça mon esprit d'une
génération nous apprenait beaucoup la
crise de 1929
oui patrice carmouze on sait qu'il est
avec lui aujourd'hui les oignons on nous
apprenait combien les mauvaises
réactions des banques centrales qui au
lieu d'ouvrir les robinets financiers
les avait fermées avec provoquer
l'aggravation de la crise et un agrès
la crise avait entraîné le monde vers la
seconde guerre mondiale donc ouvrir les
robinets
c'est ce qu'il faut faire parce qu'on ne
va pas mourir guéri ça n'aurait aucun
sens
mais ces robinets ouverts il faudra bien
les fermer un jour et de toute façon
rembourser la dette
donc oui c'est nous qui paierons alors
on paiera sans doute sous forme d'un lbo
opéra peut-être aussi par l'info des
pauvres hélas ce qui est l'inflation qui
est toujours la pire des choses pour les
plus modestes mais je vois mal comment
en ouvrant les robinets financiers
aurait pas à nouveau une résurgence de
l'inflation
il faudra essayer de contrôler toujours
est il que je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
réactions des banques centrales sur les
bonnes mais que ne nous faisons pas
d'illusions et donc soyons raisonnables
dans nos demandes
il faudra bien un jour payer la note de
toute cette histoire
m quand gérald darmanin dit que
justement il ne touchera pas la
fiscalité pour sortir de sectes de cette
crise est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça je réponds que c'est
probablement et même certainement son
attention aujourd'hui est ce que ce sera
encore la sienne demain et est-ce qu'il
sera encore là après demain je vois mal
comment à un moment donné il y aura pas
un peu de fiscalité patrice souhaité
intervenir aussi peut-être pour faire un
parallèle avec la crise de 29
non je croisais dire ce que vous avez
dit permet dit justement sur les
resteront parce que c'est un secteur
qu'ils ont plein fouet évidemment cette
île où on est encore vertus reste vous
poster ou souhaités et puisse ouvrir
avec des conditions évidemment de
précaution utile le plus rapidement
possible oui oui c'est un million
d'emplois en france des emplois non
délocalisables enfin cesser la matic
il ya les restaurants il ya les hôtels
toutes les activités ça va tellement
compliqués ne peut pas dire y'en a qui
restent confinés et d'autres qui le sont
plus de mon poignet ont ré ouvre mais en
ayant pris toutes les précautions port
du masque obligatoire température dans
les lieux accueillant plus de personnes
obligatoires même quand vous allez
acheter votre peine le boulanger bon
allez vous nous la boulangère un petit
coup dans leurs règles pour voir si vous
avez la température ou pas il faut qu'on
accepte une certaine grâce habilités de
nos déplacements pour des raisons
sanitaires et de vous à moi ça fait
longtemps que les grands opérateurs de
téléphone de toute façon dont cette
traçabilité pour à des fins commerciales
et qui ne demande pas notre avis car
bédié parmi les différentes compétences
du département il est aussi la gestion
des collèges et la question de la
réouverture des établissements scolaires
c'est ce qui préoccupe aussi aujourd'hui
les parents alors on ne sait pas quelle
date ce ça se fera il ya eu on peut le
dire tout de même une communication un
peu compliqué de la part du gouvernement
un coup les écoles ouvrez ensuite
c'était par classe ensuite ce serait sur
le volontariat des parents aussi
aujourd'hui quel est votre point de vue
sur cette réouverture des collèges et
puis guérir la réouverture des collèges
même chose il va falloir refaire
fonctionner à les cantines centrales il
va falloir faire fonctionner les
systèmes d'études de garde
la doctrine que je viens d'énoncer au
moment de l'ouverture elle est à mon
avis applicable dans les collèges
nous avons des personnels administratifs
qui peuvent très bien faire la prise de
température des élèves quand ils
arrivent le matin
s'il ya une suspicion d'infection hop
tests sérologiques sinon les gamins
rentrer et puis ils ont une activité
normale à l'intérieur du collège ont
fait la même chose d'inattendu avec les
professeurs ont fait la même chose avec
les personnels administratifs
il faut qu'on accepte alors ça veut dire
sans doute des rentrées au lieu de
rendre moins quart d'heure en collège on
va se mettre une demi-heure ou trois
quarts d'heure pour entrer donc il sera
l'adaptation sur les oreilles mais c'est
quand même pas une contrainte de
terribles que d'avoir ce système de
prise de température qui est à mon avis
la seule façon d'empêcher que ça robin
car bédié je sais qu'on est aussi
normalement fermé déchets que vous êtes
pris par le temps aussi donc on va
avancer jusqu'à un petit peu puisqu'on
parle de cette pandémie de ces
différentes conséquences du thé
confinement aussi il y a aussi des
conséquences humaines j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur la disparition de patrick
devedjian aussi votre ami président du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-seine
aujourd'hui comment vous envisagez aussi
l avenir après sa disparition pour vos
deux départements d'abord sur un plan
strictement humaine
je n'ai toujours pas criminel donc je ne
sais pas vous répondre
j'étais aux obsèques de patrick c'était
il y avait sa femme ses enfants et on
est trois élus moment moi je ne suis pas
dans la prose de monde parce que ça va
venir
j'ai naturellement en congrès dans aussi
connu de son disque dense grille donc on
ne continue à vivre ensemble mais mais
pour l'instant on fait pas de projet et
je commence à me poser des questions
comme le déconfinement sur un fini quant
au noir en bus à patrick devedjian
l'hommage qu'on doit le groupe et nomme
pas simplement parce que c'est mon ami
mais c'est étonnant exceptionnel
exceptionnelle de culture exceptionnelle
de finesse exceptionnelle d'engagement
patrick était un vrai qu'en france le
mot libéral on pense au libéralisme
économique échevelé le capitalisme des
richesses et à un libéral c'est d'abord
quelqu'un qui croit que la liberté c'est
la france
et des choses que loi proposait nos
concitoyens et un avancement discuter
avec lui je suis beaucoup moins libérale
que lui cet engagement pour la liberté
des autres était son marqueur politique
et il était de ce point de vue une
personnalité exceptionnelle est
admirable il juste justement sur ce
projet réunion est-ce qu'il ne tenait
pas quand même beaucoup à la
personnalité patrick devedjian et alain
vaute l'accord de ces deux personnalités
l'esti ps qui voit les est-ce qu'il faut
survivre au décès de patrick devedjian
ça seul l'avenir nous le dira cher
monsieur
moi mon engagement reste entier je ne
sais pas ce que le futur président élu
dans les hauts-de-seine souhaitera on a
quand même déjà mis beaucoup de choses
en commun
donc je pense que quand on va faire
l'évaluation des gains que nous avons
réalisé les uns et les autres
cette idée de fusion devrait reprendre
un certain élan alors bien évidemment la
qualité des relations des deux
présidents on est très important comme
dans toute action humaine
je sais qu'il me reste juste une une
minute pour conclure et nous poursuivons
ensuite le club de la presse avec les
journalistes des différents médias
présents pierre bettez sur les élections
municipales
aujourd'hui en quelques mots même si
c'est compliqué de tout abordé on ne
sait pas encore quand scène on veut
tenir la date du 21 juin avaient été
abordés on ne sait pas si elle pourra se
maintenir le gouvernement devrait se
prononcer à la fin du mois de mai est ce
qu'il faut tout annuler
revenir surtout sachant que si on annule
pas tout il y aura forcément aussi des
recours et j'ai une pensée pour philippe
brillault notamment le maire du chesnay
rocancourt battu de quelques voix avec
une participation de l'anp baisse de 20%
sur sa commune alors d'abord il ya une
règle de droit qui a été rappelé par le
conseil d'état donc le gouvernement il
sera tenu toutes les élections à 10 sont
acquises
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi enfin ce
serait une grande première
on supprime des élections à temps toutes
les élections qui ne sont pas guise si
elle ne se tienne pas avant la fin juin
3 2e tour
et que ce deuxième tour devait se tenir
après les mois de juillet d'août
eh bien il faudrait revoter pour les
deux tours le premier tour ne serait
plus à qui ce qui m'amène à dire qu
réfléchissons à ce que normalement un
deuxième tour j'ai fait quelques
élections en avant un deuxième tour
ça démarre le lundi matin et ça s'arrête
le vendredi soir c'est à dire cinq jours
c'est pas une ombre compagne noir
répondre personnellement qu'on peut très
bien en interdisant effectivement les
grands meetings de milliers de personnes
mais dans des réunions communales sous
réserve bien entendu ce que j'expliquais
valeur les prises de température les
personnes qui sont suspectes
on doit pouvoir tenir la jeune allemand
une réunion il n'a pas une idée soit et
donc faire cette mini compagnie lire
cinq jours pour avoir avoir parce que si
on n'a pas le groupe au mois de juin
ça veut dire que toutes les
intercommunalités sont paralysés la part
active des intercommunalités
c'est la paralysie d'où les réseaux car
maintenant tous les réseaux sont un père
comme une alizé c'est les réseaux de
transports les réseaux de ramassage des
ordures ménagères les réseaux d'eau
d'eau propre et 2 0 par exemple exagère
mais met en difficulté et se trouve que
c'est un peu dangereux voilà d'autant
qu'on a vraiment besoin de la
mobilisation tout le monde après si le
gouvernement tel que je pense va le
décider décide qu'on revote aura dans
les communes où le résultat n'a pas été
acquis en septembre et en octobre
j'espère qu'on n'attendra pas la fin
octobre parce qu'encore une fois tout ça
c'est du temps perdu pour agir au
service de nos concitoyens c'est pas
c'est pas l'intérêt des élus dont on
s'en fout d'intérêt des élus ne vous
méprenez pas sur les propos c'est que on
a besoin de voir par exemple pourquoi
j'ai réuni le conseil départemental
vendredi dernier
parce que j'avais besoin qu'il
m'autorise un certain nombre de dépenses
pour pouvoir dépenser de l'argent au
service de mes concitoyens
merci beaucoup pierre bédier président
du conseil départemental d'avoir été
versées
merci nous allons poursuivre ce club de
la presse ce club de la presse du mois
d'avril un peu particulier entre entre
journalistes à présent comme d'habitude
on fait juste une courte pause on
regarde ce reportage qui revient
justement sur les mères qui ont été
réélu dès le premier tour dans les
yvelines plusieurs maires ont été réélus
dès ce premier tour des municipales 2020
à poissy karl olive liste divers droite
remporte l'élection dans cette ville de
37 mille habitants vainqueur en 2014
avec 62,42 % des voix ils l'emportent
encore plus largement ce dimanche 15
mars
ce candidat à totalise 75 60 % des
suffrages
la hauteur de ce résultat oui je dois
avouer que c'est parce que nous nous
attendions même si on était convaincus
du travail qui était fait savez j'ai
répété pendant six ans que la réalité c
est celle du terrain en adéquation avec
les habitants moi je suis né ici j'ai
grandi ici j'aime les habitants comme
les habitants même je le crois à
saint-cyr-l'ecole la liste saint cyr au
coeur 2020 mené par sonia broc maire de
la commune depuis février 2019 s'impose
avec 55 à 60% des suffrages face à la
liste menée par lydie du long pont
assange armand les arnaud péricard en
place depuis 2010 est a lui aussi
remporté son premier succès en tant que
tête de liste
l'homme politique diverse en totalise 63
points 89 % des suffrages il devance
notamment kane richard de la liste sans
jardin écologique et solidaire et ça
prouve que les saint germanoise on
retrouve dans le projet que nous leur
avons proposé dans la rigueur qui est la
nôtre dans le sérieux et dans les
progrès que nous avons pour notre ville
pour les six prochaines années
je crois que nous sommes des gens
crédibles nous l'avons démontré pendant
six ans et nous allons leur démontrer
sur les six prochaines années
à sartrouville pierrefonds maire
historique de la commune depuis 1995 va
repartir pour un nouveau mandat sa liste
sartrouville j'aime ma ville en porte
assez facilement avec 62 27 % des
suffrages le maire sortant devance
isabella maglio terrisse à bois d'arcy
pas de souci pour la liste divers droite
philippe benassaya le maire sortant en
place depuis 2014 repartira pour un
nouveau mandat il devance e jocelyne a
nié avec 63 points 67 % à
vélizy-villacoublay pascal thévenot mer
depuis 2014 s'est lui aussi largement
imposée dès ce premier tour avec plus de
60% des suffrages
les trois autres candidats didier
blanchard hughes or seul un il ya six
mines à bellezane maths sont largement
distancés
c'est assez rare avait dit et puis avait
quand même quatre listes donc c'était
par image fin obligatoirement faciles à
l'imaginer avant on a tout fait pour
puisque aujourd'hui
finalement on est un peu les seuls à
avoir un programme est maintenant bas
c'est un peu la satisfaction des visions
sur ce qu'on a fait ces six dernières
années à versailles commune de 85 mille
habitants françois de mazières le maire
divers-droite sortant partira pour un
troisième mandat comme en 2014 elle a
été élue dès le premier tour cette fois
ci avec 63% des suffrages pas que les
versaillais était satisfait du bilan
en tout cas ils nous l'ont montré dans
le box et je leur en remercie du fond du
coeur parce que
à la vie de mère c'est une bille
totalement engagé et c'est une vie où
finalement on a un sentiment quasiment
d'infection à mantes la jolie le maire
sortant rafael cogner en place depuis
décembre 2017 a été réélu avec 72 2% des
suffrages il devance marc jamais une
liste divers gauche
enfin conflans sainte honorine a list
conflent en avant menée par laurent bros
remporte le premier tour avec plus de
51%
l'homme politique partira pour un
deuxième mandat consécutif
voilà pour ce point sur les mers en tout
cas les mères des yvelines or saint
quentin en yvelines qui ont été réélus à
l'issue du 1er tour messieurs donc je
leur précise ce club de la presse se
poursuivent sur tv soixante dix huit
avec alexandre marqué pour toutes les
nouvelles et 7,8 actus.fr nouradine agne
pour marmite fm 88 points 4 et puis et
grégory canale et patrice carmouze pour
tv 78 par rapport à ce que disait pierre
bédier on maintient le premier tour on
garde acquis et puis éventuellement il
faudra faire revoter les électeurs sur
le premier et le second tour lorsque les
résultats n'ont pas permis de désigner
un maire s'avoue semblables les uns et
les autres
moi ça me paraît très très compliqué
très compliqué d'abord parce qu'on voit
bien que juin on pourra en effet de
tenir deux réunions aller faire campagne
même s'il a raison c'est assez court et
justement j'ai peur que si des des
élections se tiennent en juin où on est
des soeurs d'élections vous rabaisser à
dire que on va voir du premier tour avec
à peu près 30 % de votants et un
deuxième tour avec peut-être encore
moins parce que les jo qui il ya quand
même eu pas mal de gens qui ont attrapé
leurs locaux vides 19 notamment des
assesseurs des gens qui étaient dans les
bureaux de vote
je pense que là il va falloir travailler
pour que des pour qu'ils viennent encore
dans les bureaux de vote je pense que
les délais des boutons seront encore
moins nombreux et que donc on risque
quand même d'avoir des élections
municipales au rap et avec des marques
comme très mal réélu même si je
comprends bien sûr son désir de faire
fonctionner la machine mais je crois que
là il ya aussi un problème démocratique
alexandre oui le gouvernement par un peu
car t2
du 21 juin je crois qu'elle compare
plutôt 20 septembre voire octobre et
même 7 en octobre
c'est pas sûr du tout manger ans en mars
qui décalerait d'autres élections s'il
ya aussi les élections régionales qui
sont prévus avant les sénatoriales aussi
ça peut poser près sûr surtout sur un
exemple concret noureddine je me tourne
vers vous puisque marmite fm et est
basée à trappes et que vous connaissez
bien cette ville si on prend une ville
comme trappe
imaginez un scrutin qui repartirait à 0
avec le long jeu qui peut y avoir des
tensions qui peut y avoir
et aussi des fois pour entrer d'autres
facteurs la difficulté de mobiliser les
électeurs
tout ça semble très compliqué je pense
que ça aurait été plus compliqué s'il y
avait eu un vainqueur dès le premier
tour
je pense qu'il aura pas de problème
particulier à refaire refaire même un
premier tour moi la question que je me
pose c'est vraiment la légitimité des
élections municipales en tant que tel
même pour les personnes qui ont été élus
dès le premier tour joue dans l'année
exemple deux exemples pour trappe par
exemple la la la participation était de
34% seulement un petit peu pile 34% 7
cette année pour trouve plus de 56 % en
montigny-le-bretonneux par exemple cette
année 37 95 au premier tour contre plus
de 56 % en 2014
voilà quelle est la légitimité même pour
des villes comme maurepas certes ou une
mère dira beaucoup d'autres villes
encore montini romaine le site est en
cours si les personnes qui ne sont
clairement pas à les ôter à cause de la
crise salutaire parler de la situation
politique pour poursuivre ce club de la
presse
peut-être faire un point et avoir
ressenti différent journalistes aussi
sur le terrain il ya une forte
solidarité qui s'est exprimé un peu
partout et qui s'est manifestée des
associations
d'illustrés inconnus aussi qui ont
souhaité se mettre à contribution
vouloir relayer dans vos médias
respectifs alexandre notamment et puis
nouradine après oui c'est l'un des
aspects positifs de cette crise
sanitaire c'est qu'il ya une solidarité
solidarité de la population
je discute et je mets reportage sur l'a6
à montigny le bretonneux qui me disait
que pour la première fois de leur vie
ils sont entrés en contact avec les
médecins de la ville de montigny ce
qu'ils aient jamais distribué les
masques et laver régulièrement et
distribue des masques
ils appellent pour avoir des nouvelles
de trois jours alors que c'est quelque
chose qui déjà n'est que cela a été un
des aspects vraiment positif pour nous
radine oui oui je suis tout à fait en
accord que ce que vient de dire à
l'exode il ya beaucoup d' associer le
monde associatif est très riche à saint
quentin en yvelines et on a couvert
leurs par téléphone moi contrairement à
alexandre alexandre un petit peu sur le
terrain de temps en temps à moi je suis
je suis ton fille née dans mon studio et
je suis obligé de passer des appels pour
couvrir les voilà les événements et ce
qui se passe ici tu vois là et des
associations qui n'est pas une surprise
à la solidarité a toujours été vraiment
un être homo que ce soit rap ou à même
dans les villes environnantes ont alors
essayé de mettre en avant vraiment ces
initiatives solidarité wilfrid des
associations comme le dit nora qui est
aussi des particuliers qui sont tous
lancés dans cet élan de solidarité
on a ouvert aussi nous notre antenne
notre chaîne à des témoignages à
distance via différents différentes
plateformes
on avait notamment reçu une île en coupe
3 1 à distance qui se proposait de faire
des courses pour les personnes âgées
celles qui ne pouvaient pas sortir et
qu'ils étaient obligés de rester dans le
confinement et on a vu aussi un élan
envers les agriculteurs où on va
peut-être en parlais tout à l'heure mais
il ya cette plateforme qui a été lancé
par le gouvernement alors ce n'est pas
du bénévolat est les personnes se
portent volontaires pour des missions
rémunérées auprès des agriculteurs et ce
sont plus de 308 personnes au travers de
la france qui sont portés volontaires
pour prêter main forte aux agriculteurs
on rappelle juste que juste avant cette
crise il y avait un contexte d'aghrib
aching de renoncement du
certaines oppositions en face au monde
agricole donc on peut aussi dire que ce
monde agricole a été a été sortie
peut-être grandi sera sera sorti grandi
de cette crise grande solidarité
également des chefs et des cuisiniers on
a relayé plusieurs fois les repas fait
par jean-christophe goody qui est un
chef basé à mumbai qui cuisinent
régulièrement pour le centre hospitalier
de versailles et qui voit là délectent
les personnels soignants 2 cm tous les
jours on voit l'effet des livraisons
tous les jours à ce centre hospitalier
patrice si on se projette un petit peu
vous imaginez tout cet élan de
solidarité se poursuivre aussi et une
réorganisation plus profonde de la
société parce qu'il ya un moment et on
l'entend aussi et je reviens sur des
considérations plus économique
il ya un moment où notamment du côté du
medef ont dit bon bah maintenant il va
falloir ci se mettre à travailler donc
c'est bien tout ce qui est solidarité
c'est bien tout ce qui engage ment je
caricature un petit peu mais vous me
direz si c'est le cas mais au-delà de ça
bon maintenant il faut travailler il
faut produire des richesses et on
revient à l'ancien monde peut-être moi
je ne suis pas très sûr oui un grand
discours sur la prensa orages mais
globalement je crois que c'est un but du
discours on entend à chaque fois qu'il
ya une crise et malheureusement ou
heureusement d'ailleurs ses points de
chute mortelle assumera je pense qu'on
revient vite aux réflexes d'abord je ne
suis pas sûr tout à fait qu'il y aura
après il va y avoir quand même une
période d' alors concrètement un peu
délicate un peu difficile qui est celle
de la sortie du virus on sait très bien
que pendant que ça risque de durer quand
même encore assez longtemps donc on doit
pas trouver un vaccin
on ne sera pas protégé donc peut-être le
la distance la distance sociale qu'on va
avoir maintenant pour nous parler des
restaurants bctq les voilà il va falloir
garder notre convivialité
peut-être le fait de se serrer la main
ou embrasser des choses qui le disent
n'être voir changer pour l'avs les
accords sociaux je pense ça va être ça
fait un petit peu compliqué cette
période de transition et que peut-être
aussi alors sur le nom du travail
la distanciation au travail le
télétravail ça ce sont des choses
peut-être qu'ils vont en effet changer
un petit peu d habitude qu'on avait une
vraie révolution avec une bande un
rendement de la triche pas trop grecque
mais des petits changements comme sa
perspective est important d'ailleurs
vraisemblable oui et puis ça concernera
tout le monde puisqu'on est dans le club
de la presse on peut dire aussi que du
côté des médias y aura forcément une
adaptation une façon de travailler
je vois tout le monde de hocher de la
tête 30 qui sortent bien évidemment
alexandre j'imagine le 11 mai je sais
pas quels ont été les directives données
par rapport aux groupes encore mais le
11 mai vous n'allez pas retourner sur le
terrain nouradine même chose tout va pas
se réouvrir le 11 mai moi j'ai jamais
vraiment jamais vraiment arrêté on
continue à faire du terrain quand il le
faut on essaie de faire au maximum des
interviews téléphone mais ça m'arrive
d'aller sur le terrain comme j'ai fait
une distribution de masques à trappes
il ya deux trois jours quand il faut y
aller c'est ce continuer ce qu'on
continue à faire et grégory confirmé
aussi sur ces vies 78 petite différence
où il vit avec eux avec alexandre c'est
que je sois tvfi loonois marmite
noureddine je vous arrête tv 78 je sais
que vous a pas vu depuis longtemps sur
notre antenne mais savez nous avons
changé de nom il ya deux ans marmite
séjour barbie marmite consul voilà c'est
mieux pour cuire d'ailleurs quand elle
écoute beaucoup
du coup je disais que la différence avec
l'exemple c'est qu'il est bon il a son
petit calepin
il peut se permettre d'avoir une
distance peut-être un peu plus important
que les personnes alors que nous que ce
sont la tv ce sont 18 ou sur marmite
voilà avec le micro tout simplement on
la tendance est beaucoup plus proche des
déjà et que du coup il ya des peut-être
des choses à revoir sur j'ai vu que
certains confrères de deux chaînes
d'info mettez des plastiques sur leurs
micros je suis pas sûr que sincèrement à
grand chose mais bon voilà il va falloir
essayer de voir comment nous aussi qui
pourront être porteur ne s'est pas
uniquement pour nous pour le protéger
s'applique aussi aux journalistes passer
la barrière beaucoup de goût c'est vrai
que le fait face considérant qu'il
permet aussi d'avoir des gens comme
comme comme on est actuellement par
visioconférence ça permet aussi d'avoir
des gens qu'on n'aurait peut-être pas
enfin c'est plus difficile de
transporter jusqu'à un studio d'avoir
des gens dans sa montre aussi les
perspectives mince elle s'est pas c'est
pas seulement négatif c'est aussi
positif moi et puis ça permet de voir la
décoration chez chacun aussi voilà le
rapport humain le manque d'humanité
c'est sur alexandre aussi grégory
voulait intervenir après est ce qu'on
peut dire aussi c'est que cette épidémie
va aussi poser des problèmes économiques
aussi à la presse on a pu voir par
exemple paris normandie se trouve en
très grande difficulté ça il était déjà
fragile avant et ça les a fragilisés
encore plus en raison de pertes de
recettes publicitaires concrètement et
puis j'ai une pensée d'ailleurs pour nos
partenaires habituels de ce club de la
presse que ce soit que ce soit la radio
lfm ou encore les gazettes qui
d'habitude participé avec nous et qui
aujourd'hui sont vraiment effectif plus
que réduit en chômage partiel pour une
grande partie et qui ont dû stopper
aussi leurs activités et grégory
pourquoi pas à l'avenir sur tv 78 plutôt
que de faire des simples ce qu'on
appelle mon jargon incertaine et
phonique c'est à dire d'avoir à la
personne par téléphone pour une
interview multiplier ce genre de contenu
à distance pour avoir les personnes
aussi visuellement chez elle voir aussi
leur petit leur petit chez eux
voilà patrice un dernier mot c'est
l'occasion
c'est l'occasion d'un mec c'est vrai
comme on dit qu'elle est en droit la
situation notamment le confinement est
très difficile parce que c'est des
exploits c3 parce qu'on a vécu de sortir
beaucoup plus comme on dit est ce que
est ce que vous avez ce sentiment qu
aider dans des quartiers où ça doit être
très compliqué alors pour vous répondre
honnêtement patrice
il faut vraiment recontextualiser la
chose pour comprendre ce qui se passe
non pas seulement à prat mais dans les
quartiers populaires en général pour
celles et ceux qui ont la chance d'avoir
un jardin une maison c'est sûr que c'est
beaucoup plus facile de vivre
inconsciemment quand on habite dans une
barre d'immeuble où ils y achètent pas
12 15 étages il est dans des logements
souvent un petit oui moi on a plus
tendance à se sortir même si ce n'est
pas uniquement voilà à sortir pour
promenèrent pour être devant devant le
bâtiment
voilà pour pour tout simplement pour
pouvoir espérer sspa l'inde et ce qui
est d'ailleurs tout à fait autorisé avec
avec une attestation
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des points
chauds notamment lors de contrôles de
police qui ont un peu un peu dégénéré
nous nous voilons pas la face après la
situation aujourd'hui est la situation
d'hier c'est la même des cas difficiles
qu'on l'a attrapée dans les autres
quartiers pour les cas difficiles qui
sont toujours présents
en gros pour parler de façon triviale ce
n'est pas un scoop qu'il ya des voyous
par exemple qui qui vivaient dans
certains quartiers qui sont toujours
voyous ils sont pas lui de ils ont pas
mis de côté leurs activités parce que
c'était le confinement ou parce qu'ils
ont eu peur du comité non à la france ça
c'est la réalité qu'il faut pas lire
mais globalement je vous dirais de façon
en tout cas moi ce que j'ai pu constater
et que le continent a été respectée à 99
% des cas dans dans les quartiers de
crapauds merci à tous les cinq patrie je
vais vous chez vous libérez parce qu'on
va passer aux toutes dernières séquences
d'émission sur les personnalités et puis
les prochainement à la une dans les
différents médias merci avoue patrice à
bientôt on vous retrouve prochainement
sur notre antenne notamment pour paf
confiné aussi avec des chroniqueurs
merci patrice très joli très joli chez
vous aussi pas mal merci patrice quand
nous passons aux personnalités du mois à
présent
les personnalités du mois ils pourraient
être nombreuses au vu de l'implication
de chacun pendant cette crise pour
débuter nouradine c'est plutôt un
hommage que vous vouliez rendre
aujourd'hui oui tout à fait on voulait
rendre un hommage à notre ancien ou marc
paquin un des premiers animateurs de
sueur marmite fm dans les années
2002-2003 il animé notamment
il co animé avec d'autres personnes une
émission bilingue peu pour parler de la
culture peut donc la culture peule dont
les les poulets recommandé actionnaires
al shoula habitent principalement autour
du fleuve sénégal est un peu plus
largement autour du fleuve sénégal et du
coup voilà il a été emporté par le cos
vite que c'était un médiateur notamment
qui travaillaient sur saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un amoureux de cette
culture dont je viens de vous parler de
la culture peule il était poète
également est engagé notamment dans la
lutte contre l'esclavagé en mauritanie
voilà donc c'est un hommage que je
voulais me rendre alors il est pas le
seul à être parti rpt pense également à
khemisti marc miquel président de
l'association et tu t'es que multimédia
à trappes
et puis voilà plus largement vraiment
faire un hommage à et puis on penser à
toutes les familles de toutes celles et
tous ceux qui nous ont quittés pendant
qu'ils vont certainement le kit est
encore pendant cette crise ducobu notre
côté pour tv 78 c'est une profession que
nous mettons plutôt à l'honneur ce mois
ci celle des pharmacies encore une fois
on aurait pu évoquer les infirmiers les
médecins les enseignants les et boire
aussi là ce sont les formations non
seulement ils dispensent des conseils
des livres des médicaments et puis on en
a parlé tout à l'heure avec vous
alexandre il distribue aussi des masques
aux soignants notamment il faut aussi
noter que les patients qui désertent les
cas est-ce que les cabinets médicaux ou
encore les hôpitaux
bah maintenant ce sont les formations
qu'ils vont voir alors ils sont en
première ligne pour traiter les petits
soucis du quotidien les autres
pathologies et ils ont même fabriqué
pour plusieurs les leurs propres
solutions hydroalcooliques et puis
demain pourquoi pas on va leur demander
aussi de réaliser des tests de dépistage
du coc vide donc eu que nous mettons
aujourd'hui en avant
grégory on n'avait pas préparé cette
séquence mais ce cas une personnalité
qui vous revient en tête sur toutes
celles que vous avez pu recevoir ces
derniers temps et je parlais tout à
l'heure ce chef de maurepas
jean-christophe roddick on a interrogé
au début de ce continent qui est l'un
des chefs référant à des collèges
yvelinois il cuisine pour les cuisines
centrales de ses collègues yves hinant
et très vite au début de cette crise on
a vu plusieurs chefs se lancer dans
cette initiative il a été l'un des
premiers dans les yvelines à la mettre
en place
c'est à dire cuisiner des plats pour le
personnel soignant des lasagnes des
plages et des fondants au chocolat aussi
voilà il ya du dessert également très
vite et il a fait pour le centre
hospitalier de versailles il a réuni
autour de lui plusieurs acteurs donc lui
comme il est moins bien il a fait appel
au commerce de maurepas ya notamment le
soir commercial paris-ouest auchan morin
qui s'est joint à cet élan et donc
chaque jour ils acheminent amène ses
repas pour les personnels soignants de
l'hôpital mignot au chesnay rocancourt
le centre hospitalier de versailles
voilà et puis il y en a d'autres qui
nous montre aussi qu'il est capable
alors non seulement de bien manger mais
aussi après de se dépenser un petit peu
fait je pensais à sidy diallo alexandre
oui ça un peu plus léger c'est donc moi
je pensais à sidy diallo donc qui a
coureurs un peu hors normes
il vit à montigny le bretonneux et donc
à 65 ans il a déjà couru 225 marathon et
ultra marathons dont 70 pieds nus parce
que déjà une performance est là en plein
confinement il a décidé de courir un
marathon dans son appartement donc sur
un parcours de 2 25 m donc il a effectué
huit cent quarante quatre allers-retours
dans son département
donc il s'est lancé le matin à 7h du
matin et il a fini à 21h53 et le tout
sans douleur ni courbature et bien
nouradine c'est à vous dans les locaux
de marmites
allez-y petite précision pour rebondir
sur ce que disait alexandre ces procès
complètement par hasard parce qu'on
rectifie ce des portraits de
personnalités qu'on l'avait reçue sur
barbie jeudi prochain à 17h30 c'est le
portrait de sidy diallo qui est diffusée
sur voir mythe
sur leur but est faible et j'ajouterais
nous révéler alexandre que cette semaine
aussi nous on allons maîtriser sur les
78 reportage sur cydia lusa mais
laissons les images les imiter résultat
c'est un peu votre personnalité donc
donc du mois en tout cas voilà celle que
vous avez mis en avant aujourd'hui
alexandre nous arrivons bientôt la fin
de cette émission aux dernières
séquences à présente bientôt à la une
bientôt à la une les sujets que vos
médias locaux vont relayer dans les
prochains jours alexandre vous laisse la
parole à nouveau à bientôt dans toutes
les nouvelles et 7,8 actus.fr un premier
point aussi sur la situation du monde
culturel
oui on a prévu de faire un dossier de
trois pages sur les lieux culturels des
yvelines mes collègues et moi on a on a
interrogé des directeurs de salle pour
faire le point a poussé sur le
département
parce qu'ils ont été durement touchés
par la crise sanitaire avec des
spectacles annulés et reportés et ils
sont très inquiet pour la prochaine
rentrée savoir s'il va les prochaines
saisons pouvoir soutenir si les gens
vont pouvoir venir dans leur salle
s'ils vont avoir envie si on peut avoir
peur donc un point sur tout ça sur les
intermittents aussi conclu de contrat et
donc pas de cachet voilà donc un point
complet sur le département sur les
différentes salles sur la scène
nationale de saint quentin hr
sartrouville a regardé en ville oui
parce que les saisons se sont se termine
de toute façon on est arrivé sur la fin
du mois de mai juin mais après en
septembre la grande question c'est oui
est ce que les artistes vont monter sur
scène et puis est-ce que les gens auront
aussi envie d'y aller est ce que au
final tout le monde voudra bien sortir
et reprendre une vie plus ou moins
normal noureddine bientôt sur marmite fm
des témoignages de résidents d pad aussi
oui c'est ça notamment alors pas des
résidents de personnel n'est pas
personnel serait qu'ils vont nous dire
comment se mettre en place justement
toutes ces nouvelles mesures barrières
leur pierre bédier nous en a parlé un
petit peu avec les tests qui devraient
commencer à se répandre un peu partout
dans les yvelines du combat on va avoir
des témoignages dans ce sens là on va
également parler d'eux
de ce qu'a évoqué patrie patrice tout à
l'heure avec la situation dans certaines
banlieues on va essayer d'avoir des
témoignages de ce côté là et notamment
par rapport à ce qu'on appelle des
violences policières
parce que c'est également un thème très
important pendant cette période de
confinement et puis on essaiera de
parler également pour terminer les amap
et de cette agriculture de proximité qui
sera peut-être tout al heure grégory
parler de la grippe aching avant l'avant
de confinement justement est-ce que la
donne va changer avec avec son
confinement
même si les français étaient très
attachés à la lutte contre les
pesticides notamment et contre
glyphosate est ce que ça va pas
retourner justement la situation avec ce
qu'on filme voilà merci à vous trois
d'avoir participé à ce club de la presse
du mois d'avril sur tv 78 merci donc à
vous je rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver nouradine agne sur l'antenne
de marmites fm 88.4 chaque mercredi
notamment à 17 heures pour un point
complet les articles d'alexandre marqués
sont à lire sur 7,8 actus.fr et puis
dans toutes les nouvelles chaque
mercredi voici d'ailleurs les unes des
deux dernières éditions sur saint
quentin en yvelines versailles puis et
puis rambouillet et puis pour tv 78
durant cette période nous vous donnons
rendez vous à 19 heures chaque soir pour
notre édition spéciale quand on a un
virus et confinement merci à vous enfin
de nous avoir suivis prenez soin de vos
proches et de vous et à très bientôt
[Musique]